welcome to the Drew Barrymore show I'm
Brandon Marshall I am back yes
some of you may know me as an NFL player
but I'm putting on my referee hat today
for the next edition of Drew's design
duel
team I need to introduce and our first
team is a TV darling and that's Drew
Barrymore yeah okay and then we're
talking about the best of the best
then are you ready to throw down your
design Town yes I just found out Ben
told me he's not competitive
um which is interesting because I have
enough for both of us I'm not
competitive
let me introduce her competitors but you
need to give him a pep talk because it's
going down yeah we have funny guy and
funny man Ross Matthews
and we have Ben's wife the queen Aaron
Napier
[Applause]
so Drew and I are very they're gonna be
Drew versus not to happen right now all
right listen I'm the referee enough of
that enough of that all right you got
rules you have rules okay each team has
identical walls and chairs the goal is
to decorate these spaces with the items
on this table right here okay okay and
we want to design the ultimate reading
Nook do we have it oh the ultimate do we
have it all right you guys are going to
actually be designing for this side of
the audience because there's an Ultimate
Prize later okay so Drew and Ben's going
to be designing for you guys okay do we
have it all right when I say go your
deck what are they doing when I say go
they're going to decorate until I say
stop the audience will then vote on
their faith okay all right here we go
ready set design let's go
let's go
what are you guys thinking here what's
the plan that would go well with you
guys they're designing for you guys they
gotta get going he's not that
competitive right now Big Ben
let's go
they're rolling do you guys feel good
about your size
pull down and I'm going to
go if you want to see listen reading
notes we're supposed to be comfortable
right but it's supposed to give you some
spark of energy because you want to keep
going you don't want to fall asleep and
you're reading note so let's see what's
happening here Drew what's happening
what's happening what are you what's the
plan uh Brandon we're thinking about
wallpapering but
like a stick and peel wait what if we
measure another exacto knife it out okay
okay I was just gonna let it hang off
and then you oh really okay they're
rolling here Aaron and Ross is rolling
you guys feel good about Aaron and Ross
[Applause]
all right I'm gonna slide down here this
is the part that takes the most time so
let me ask you a question Ross yes I
heard that well I heard that uh uh Drew
yeah just designed your apartment and
redecorated your apartment
I think he's working are you drawing any
inspiration from that um yeah Drew did
such a beautiful job which doesn't mean
I don't want to beat her today
what they say is the couple that compete
against each other they stay together no
no no no no no no that ain't what they
say that ain't what they say no no no no
no no what's going on over here I see no
action over here what is happening do
you guys need help go ahead and cut it
you want a phone a friend yeah
all right lights out all right Brandon
question when it comes to wallpaper am I
straight
I don't think you'll ever be straight I
don't think you'll ever be straight Ross
that's up to you okay Ross no Ross we
love you the way you are
I don't know what's happening over here
see what these boxes are yeah
we're going to reveal what's in here oh
a little later what do you think about a
little rolled up little you know you
guys think you're into it okay there's
so much more you guys can use you have
the whole table the whole table listen
there's no shelves oh wait hold on yeah
no there's shells we got to build them
we're going to don't worry
if you guys feel good about where Drew
and Ben are Make some noise
I don't know
I feel a little I feel a little a little
biased right there if you guys feel good
about Aaron and Ross making a little
noise
okay
Drew you love reading Nooks what's the
inspiration here what do you think uh
makes a great reading Nook um
flipping and that
always helps
um and and a nice soft pillow so that
you can support your neck yep
oh just squeeze that in there
I got you thank you Brandon I don't know
if I'm supposed to be doing this as a
referee I'm gonna say I may be
disqualifying myself
but there you go
Ross what do you think about a reading
Nook
[Applause]
guys guys come here we have a mystery
box come here what come here come open
up this Mystery Box come here Ross Ross
here now now Drew Ben down stop the show
stop it right now where's the mystery
here we go right here
we have two items in here you need to
incorporate it until you make yourself
right now yes open it up oh my gosh
but it's a cat clock and a skull book
ends are you kidding me yes okay listen
they're going to keep decorating
throughout the break we're gonna go to
commercial then we come back all right
we'll see who's leading the way all
right we'll see you guys next
[Music]
foreign